here's what we know so far north las
vegas leaders wrapped up a press
conference just over an hour ago with
the latest updates now this happened at
the intersection of cheyenne and
commerce in north las vegas police tell
us nine people have died including a
family of three adults and four children
they also tell us the driver ran a red
light speed is considered a factor here
the north las vegas police chief also
announced today that the ntsb will be
assisting with this investigation and
north las vegas has never seen a crash
of this magnitude before
madison kimbrough was at today's press
conference she joins us live with more
on what we know so far madison
north las vegas police department and
mayor lee as well as north las vegas
officials from all around gathered here
at city hall today to talk about the
horrific crash that occurred saturday
afternoon just after 3 and with the
updated information police say the dodge
challenger which caused the crash had
two people inside both died there was a
toyota sienna that had seven occupants
all of which died as well one driver in
a ford fusion was taken to the hospital
and is currently fighting for their life
the other drivers both in a chevy malibu
and mercedes all made it out ok
here's what acting nlvpd chief
jacqueline gravitt had to say
speed was a factor
in this accident
and that is the only contributing factor
that we know of at this time
the sole vehicle heading northbound on
cheyenne
again was occupied by two individuals
due to the magnitude of this injury the
ntsb will be assisting us with this
investigation the red cross has been in
contact with our agency because they
want to reach out to those families and
we are currently diligently working on
providing those families information
again police saying the horrific crash
happened shortly after 3 p.m saturday
afternoon on cheyenne and commerce the
driver in the dodge challenger who ran
the red light died in the crash keep it
here on 8 news now as we bring you the
latest information reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now